life really sucks sometimes and I have
definitely on occasion wondered why bad
things seem to be drawn to me like I'm
some sort of magnet but thinking about
this for a bit recently it has led me to
think about birthday cake I should point
out by the way that this video wasn't
just an excuse to eat a cake though I am
still going to do that your body is made
of an uncountable number of atoms bear
with me here a whole bunch of different
atoms are mostly hydrogen carbon oxygen
but more interestingly those atoms have
come from really interesting places
because there are so many atoms in your
body you and every other person alive
today has about 200 billion atoms in
them that were once in William
Shakespeare in fact we all have about
200 billion atoms of pretty much any
dead famous person you can think of in
us so William Shakespeare the Buddha
Marie Curie because generally in our
lifetimes atoms just don't get created
or destroyed though they can be through
nuclear processes most of the time if
you find a particular atom that atom has
been that atom for a very long time so
you can trace where the atoms in your
body come from this one in my finger for
example as an oxygen atom that used to
be in Leonardo da Vinci this hydrogen
atom in my hair I breathed in two days
ago though it's best that I don't get
overly attached to any one of these
atoms we turn them over at a pretty
colossal rate with our surroundings just
by doing human things like breathing
going back to the cloakroom
Pranav what I find most interesting to
think about is this every atom in me
must have come from somewhere it must
have some source or other and while we
do exchange them with our environment a
huge rate every day some of them will
been with us for a very long time some
of the atoms in me will have come all
the way from the human starter-kit that
my mum made and so come from her well
some of my other atoms will have come
from the drink that I had five minutes
ago and now some of my atoms have come
from this chocolate cake consider this
you still have atoms in you from every
birthday cake you've ever had
a very small number in the grand scheme
of your body but they're still there
you are made partly of birthday cake and
extending this you are made of
everything that has ever gone into you
you are literally made of breakfasts of
family dinners of late-night and totally
necessary cheesy chips your body is the
product of all of the inputs that have
ever gone into it and each one of those
inputs in some small way still exists in
you now I talked about birthday cake
here because it's pretty much
universally thought of as a positive
thing by everyone loves birthday cake
but I could have talked about something
a bit more negative I could have talked
about the fact that you are partly made
of late-night comfort food eating
sessions where you try and drown your
bad feelings in carbs or the fact that
you are partly made of the icky cough
medicine that you were force-fed as a
child so what does all of this have to
do with bad things happening to you well
in the same way that your body is made
of birthday cake out of cough medicine
your mind is the product at every event
that has ever happened to you it's
partly made from birthday parties and
partly made from funerals from great
victories and from crushing defeats
every experience in your life to date
has shaped who you are today now
includes both the good stuff and the bad
now you can't help the fat that's bad
things are going to happen to you that's
just part of the deal of being alive in
exactly the same way that you can't
control the fact that some of your atoms
are going to come from nice sources and
some are going to come from not so nice
sources the difference though between
the atoms that make up your body and the
events that make up your mind is that
you have no control over how the atoms
in your body determine your life you do
however have power over how the events
that have happened to you determine who
you are the events you can't change but
you can choose how you interpret those
events how you let them affect you and
whether they have a positive influence
on you or a negative one to ask why do
bad things happen to me just isn't
meaningful bad things happen to everyone
by merit of being alive the choice you
have is how you allow the bad things
that happen to you to affect the rest of
your life so really the question you
should be asking is how do I deal with
the bad things that have happened to me
you can choose to learn from them or
choose to see them as a reflection on
you as a person if you choose to learn
from them hard
that may be then in the future you will
be better equipped to deal with bad
things happening to you whether that
means changing your habits or changing
your thought patterns in response to the
bad things on the other hand if you just
accept the fact that bad events
happening to you is a reflection on you
as a person then you're not going to
benefit in any way at all from them
happening to you you're not going to
learn anything and that to me seems a
wasted opportunity if bad stuff is going
to happen to you which spoiler alert it
will then you may as well try and take
some positives from a bad situation and
try and learn something if you don't
already do this then maybe the next time
something bad happens try it out
remember a failure isn't a failure
unless you fail to learn I hope that you
enjoyed this video I know I did and that
you've taken something away from it that
will help you in your life in some small
way please do leave your stories down in
the comments below about how you've
learned from bad events that have
happened in your life and if you enjoyed
the video then please consider giving it
a like thanks very much for watching and
it was completely related to the point
the program so I basically look a whole
bunch of productivity because it's taken
again adjusting Throgs for life was
something easy tough I was going to feel
so welcomed by everybody instigated that
it really is defenders college and
instantly fell at home so that was easy
the hard part was dealing with the word